Yes, okay. This isn't my question, but
um
why should
It's a question on modesty. Why should
women wear skirts and dresses? And can
you show from the Bible and also spirit
of prophecy as well? Why should women
wear skirts and dresses?
All right.
Modesty
is a is a difficult concept to define in
precise terms because modesty varies
from culture to culture.
I've been to India
on a couple of occasions
and an Indian lady will be coming to
church and all of this is exposed.
But that's modest in India.
That's not modest in Little Rock. Are
you following me?
And so don't tell me I saw a woman do
No, no, no, that's modest in India. I
was in Ghana and there was a guy on the
pulpit.
He seemed to be wrapped in a bedsheet.
It wasn't a bedsheet, but it looked just
wrapped just around and and he most of
this out and he was
but that's modest
in Ghana.
And so modesty depends on where you are,
but there is a unifying theme regarding
modesty and that theme is the Holy
Spirit of God.
The Spirit of God will guide and do you
see the church cannot provide
microscopic guidance in every little
detail of the believer's life. There
must be room for the Spirit of God to
say don't do that, don't do that, don't
do that.
And so what I recommend to you is you
ask
Last night I said
everything must be done for the glory of
God.
Before you dress
before you buy your outfit, dress,
pants, whatever, shoes. Before you go to
the barber for a hairstyle, you ladies,
men too.
Ask God.
Father
is this for your glory?
If it's not
keep waiting for the spirit to convict
you. I was in Namibia
and I was talking to young people one
Sunday morning
and I stressed the principle of for the
glory of God without exception. The way
you dress, your hair, your shoes, your
relationships, your food, every single
thing, will this glorify God? And there
was a young lady present.
She had a
a hairstyle.
I mean this thing was huge.
I like to call it an eagle's nest
sitting on her head. That's the way it
looked.
And I said, "Okay, all right." Next
morning I was doing one-to-one
counseling and she came and I didn't
recognize it.
She said, "You recognize me?" I said,
"No." She said, "I am the lady who had
this Oh!" I said, "What happened?" She
said, "As I listened to you
I was convicted because I realized I did
not make this choice for the glory of
God.
I was simply following fashion."
And she cut it off the very day.
Went off into canvassing. I mean just a
conviction on hairstyle took her into
canvassing
and medical missionary work. She was
convicted. I was in Bermuda conducting
week of prayer.
And this guy came every day. He's a
Rastafarian.
He has these dreadlocks and you know and
they shush.
Okay.
And Jesus died for the whole world, not
just for people with short hair or no
hair. And so he came, he came.
The Sabbath morning for baptism, he went
to the back of the church
and came back and nobody recognized him.
He had brought his scissors to church
with him.
Something in the week of prayer
convicted this man. He cut the whole
thing off
because he knew honestly
that this was not for God's glory. Let
me tell you what's missing in many of
our decisions, honesty.
We will not be honest with ourselves. I
chose that shoe because I want to look
good. I was not thinking of God's glory
at all.
Let me tell you this, guaranteed, if you
ask first, is this for the glory of God?
Your choices will change. All of this is
about modesty. Modesty will be directed
by the Spirit of God as you give
yourself to Christ and allow him to
direct your choices, whether it's a tie
or shirt.
I'm not an example of anything, but let
me tell you.
Because I travel a lot
I'm always on planes.
Ellen White said to the preacher, "When
the preachers get up in the pulpit, you
should wear dark suit
because you make an effect even before
you open your mouth.
You have an effect on people." She said,
"Let the effect be positive by the way
you look." And all
experts in psychology will agree with
that now.
And so I would ask God, "Father
what tie should I wear
on the plane?"
Literally.
So I ask my wife, "Which tie?"
I've stood in the bathroom with two or
three ties in my face and said, "Father,
which one?" I've actually had ties on
and then taken them off because the
spirit said, "Not that one.
This one."
That tie may turn somebody off.
Literally.
And so I ask
when I began doing that, you will not
believe the thing the experiences I've
had.
When I started asking God what shirt to
wear
and what tie
and what suit.
I would ask him.
Now, I can't say I heard a voice, but
you get impressions.
I was a leaving, I think it was Nigeria.
These things actually began happening to
me.
And I'm coming down with my little
handbag, dressed.
And the immigration guy saw me coming.
He said, "Come, Bishop, come."
So I said to him when I got to the desk,
"Why do you call me Bishop?"
He said, "It's obvious you're a
preacher." I said, "Why do you say
that?" He said, "The anointing is all
over you."
And he took off his cap. He said, "Bless
me."
And so I dropped a blessing on him.
I was in South Africa. And these things
began to happen and I was coming again
through security and the guy said to me,
"Come, preacher."
When I got to my said, "Why do you call
me preacher?" He said, "But you look
like one."
I said, "Okay." Then I went to another
officer a little further down because
you have multiple security checks. He
said, "Come, come, preacher." He didn't
hear my first interaction. I said, "Why
do you call me preacher?" He said, "But
you look like one."
Said, "Okay." I was another trip to
South Africa. I was going to a campus a
university campus to preach to students.
University of Witwatersrand outside
Johannesburg or in Johannesburg. We were
driving, my driver and I, and I told
him, "Pull in by that gas station. I
wanted some gum, you know, Americans
love chewing gum."
So he pulled in and I went to one little
store like a 7-Eleven and I said, "Do
you have gum?" She said,
"Yes." She gave me the gum. I said, "Do
you have juice?" She said, "No."
So I got the juice.
No, I asked her for juice first, for
juice.
She went to get the juice and the juice
was
right next to the liquor.
So I said, "You're close to the liquor
section. Is that juice?" She said, "I
would never give you liquor." I said,
"Why not?" She said, "You're a
preacher."
I said, "How do you know that?" She
said, "It was obvious you're a
preacher."
I went to the next store right next door
to get the gum.
The guy said, "Come, Bishop."
And so I said
I'm getting irritated now. "Why do you
call me that?" He said, "But you look
like one."
All this began to happen when I
literally began to ask God "What tie?
What shirt?
What suit?"
I'm not joking.
What am I telling you? Ask God.
When you stand in front of those dresses
"Which one should I pick?"
Forget Beyoncé. Ask God.
"Which one should I pick?" Forget Lil
Nas. Ask God.
"What shirt should I buy?" You know,
forget whomever. Ask God. "How should I
fix my hair?" Ask him. I'm telling you,
if you listen, he'll tell you, "Not
that.
Not that." I've seen women in church on
high heels so high.
I said, "Lord, if she wanted to commit
suicide, she could just jump off those
shoes.
She doesn't need a building. Are you
following me? Just jump off those shoes
and she's dead. These things are so
high."
So I
ask God. Are you with me? And the Lord
will direct you. He'll speak to your
conscience.
All right.
God bless you.